Hey, what's up everybody?
I think we're on what day? 16.
Uh, GI sent you a message in the, uh,
SMC room, if you can look at that.
That's kind of urgent. How's everybody doing? Good.
Is everybody doing good? So, uh,
I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
I had a, um, really, really bad migraine last night.
Uh, just some internal conflict stuff going down,
and it kind of had an effect on me yesterday.
I don't really deal well attention to stress anymore.
Uh, so I didn't, I didn't do much last night. A little bit.
I did. Uh, I would say that this is the first time
that I ran into a roadblock.
It was kind of frustrating.
I'm gonna share that with you so you guys know how
to troubleshoot, even though I don't have a solution yet.
I just want you to see, um, you know,
all the processes I went through.
'cause you guys will come up against that.
Um, can you guys, uh,
let me know if anybody has any issues at all if you are
disconnected, whatever it is.
Can you guys put your hand up?
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Um, lemme just make sure, uh, hold on a second.
I had somebody that joined today, like, beg me to, uh, join.
I'm just gonna make sure. Are you joining?
I'm like, we're, we're at the tail end of this thing,
but you can come into the next one.
But he's like, no, no, I gotta buy.
Um, I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
Uh, I don't understand.
I'm gonna share some things with you guys.
Uh, but let me, let me fill the waters yet.
Are you guys not wanting to?
Is, is there anybody here that is trying to build a, uh,
build up their reputation, their brand, build an audience,
build a list, build a following?
Is there anybody looking to do that?
Because, I mean, I've used this expression a hundred times,
but right now it is stealing candy from a baby.
I, I, I've never seen guys, I've never seen the kind
of engagement that I'm seeing right now.
And, and I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna tell you right now,
like I, I got a lady, uh, let me, let me share this.
This is not the first time this has happened.
I don't do well with, uh, I I don't,
I I do, I do well with groups.
I don't necessarily do well with like one-on-one things,
but I got a lady that just sent me a message last night.
I haven't had a chance to get to her.
'cause you know, I'm, I'm trying to help you guys.
Um, but this lady flat out said she saw one of my posts.
Um, I'll, I'll definitely reach out to her.
Um, but this is, this is what she said. Here.
Let me see if I can open this up.
'cause I, I wanna, I'm, I'm, I'm just kind of blown away
that, um,
people are not, not doing this.
So let me grab this here, and I'll just open this up.
Um, there we go. Okay.
So if I share my screen, like, guys,
I keep getting messages like this.
Hi Chad. I've only just come across
you in an open claw group.
I'm willing to spend three K on the open claw setup.
You mentioned here, you said it's not actually three K,
but I have the team and I'd love to do this, please.
And I'm like, and I keep, I keep getting these messages
where people are like, what's it gonna cost?
What's it gonna cost for you to build this out for me?
What's it gonna cost? And I'm going, wait a minute.
I, I told, I told everybody on our, our shadow intensive,
my team will install it for free for you.
We, we will install it and onboard it for free.
You don't even have to worry about that.
You just gotta collect the money.
I, I have, I have nothing to gain from that, by the way,
nothing to gain except making you super, super happy and,
and profitable, right?
So the little things I do, the little frustrations,
man, my shirt, I promise you it was up in the cupboard.
I can't stand it when shirts are ironed like that.
Not ironed. But, um, when, uh, um,
when I'm posting on my wall, I'm getting followers
and people are messaging me,
and what am I posting on my wall?
This thing's p*****g me off. Look what it's telling me.
Or I can't figure this out. Or look what I did.
Figure out, like, I'm just posting
that I'm using this thing.
Do you guys understand that?
There's no magic there.
I I'm just constantly posting
because people are following and, and then,
and then messaging,
and then saying, Hey, can I just hire you to do?
And I'm like, why am I the only one doing this?
Every once in a while, I see somebody make a post
and they're trying to sell.
Don't sell, guys, don't sell. Don't sell it.
Don't sell it, right?
Remember, everybody wants to buy,
but nobody wants to be sold.
Don't sell it at all. You don't have to.
By you showing that you're making progress
with it, you're selling.
Everybody else is struggling with trying to get the install
and everything by you showing
that you're making progress with it, you're selling.
Does that make sense? Does
everybody understand this right now?
Is everybody starting to get this?
Um, here's the other thing,
and let me, let me kind of show you, okay?
I, I'm telling you, man, it is stealing candy from the baby.
And I don't know the reason why you guys
are not all doing this.
Okay? So let me show you this.
She came from another group, so I got all these people
telling me right now,
but you could see that I didn't get any response to this.
Okay, fine, then I'll freaking delete it. That's fine.
Um, but look, I'm, I'm trying to go live as much
as I can, right?
I'm posting, I posted this in another group,
and they call me a bunch of scammers.
They're like, so your open claw went
and built a get rich quick scam.
I'm like, oh my God, you guys are idiots, right?
So, um, but you could see that I'm,
I'm just constantly, some of 'em win.
Some of 'em don't, but it doesn't mean
that people don't see it.
So I'm gonna leave this one up here.
It doesn't mean that people don't see it.
I'm just constantly posting, constantly making videos,
constantly asking questions.
And as a result, my stuff over here, oh,
I gotta go check and see what happens here.
But my stuff over here is just blowing up.
But I'm gonna show you something else too.
Uh, there's not a lot of groups that are letting me do this.
Chad. Wrong screen, wrong screen. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you. All right.
Share, share screen one. All right. Do you see it?
Now it just goes to show you, like, you don't even have
to know how to share a,
a button on Zoom, and you can do this.
But look, look, I'll have to go
and see what's happened in the ever lesson group.
I can't remember what I posted,
but this guy here said to me, yeah,
please post as much as you can.
So in this group, uh, yeah, this is a post
where they all called me a scammer last night.
Um, but here's the thing, guys.
This is what I wanna point out on the phone. On the phone.
I can come over here on the phone
and everybody that likes my post,
I could invite them to be a friend.
Do, do you guys, do you guys understand this right now?
So this is my wall, but let me, let me go into my, my group.
I thought I was in that group. Hold on, let me find it.
Um, so, and,
and by the way, I, I saw my own group
that I completely forgot, which is this one.
Uh, last time I showed you guys, it had 200 members.
It's now up to 585 members.
And I'm not inviting a single person, guys.
It's just a hot topic.
And so I take it, I post it on my wall,
I post it in this group, and I
post it in somebody else's group.
And I wish I could just have a VA doing this
all the time, but I can't.
I cannot get there. So all of these people, now,
unfortunately, let me see if that's the case.
All of these people over here on, um, Facebook,
let me see if I can do,
I didn't invite none of these people.
I have no idea who any of these people are, right?
But let me see if I can get back in here.
I, I don't like the changes that Facebook has made.
Um, but all these people let me there. Okay?
You can do it a little bit different.
Look, all these people that look,
all these people are now going to
get notifications on my wall,
and they're clearly all interested in open claw.
Is this making sense to you guys?
How, how many of you're starting to get this right now?
You can't do this from the phone, unfortunately,
but, uh, hey, we can do it from here, right?
So everybody that accepts, they're, they're all gonna get,
uh, they're all gonna get my messages, right?
Um, make sure y'all attend
the webinar where we're going
to, going to build
about a business in real time tomorrow,
uh, tomorrow, 2:00 PM PST 5:00 PM EST.
Yeah, man, I'm gonna tell you right now,
there is nobody doing what I am doing.
And there's no reason at all why you
guys cannot be doing it.
I'm not gonna come down on you
and be like, Hey, why are you promoting open club?
No, I want you to do it.
I want you, I want you to build a following.
Don't worry about me. I want you to build a following.
Even if everything that I'm teaching you,
if you started posting on your wall
or whatever, I'm fine with it.
I'm totally fine with it.
There's a, hmm, there's, there's enough.
What the heck is this? You want automatically welcome new
members in your group admin?
Uh, no, I don't think so. I don't think so.
But look, there's 585 people here
that I can go through later on.
I'll have, I'll have a, I'll have a VA do it.
I don't have time. But in addition to that, guys,
so I posted my own group that I created, uh,
just a couple weeks ago.
I threw, I didn't even, I just asked Chad
g PT to make a cover.
I put no effort into it, none whatsoever.
But then I wanna show you this.
There's somebody else's group that I keep posting in.
Um, oh my gosh, I cannot, I'm telling you guys,
I have never seen the kind of engagement that I'm seeing.
Okay? So look at this one. This is a different group, okay?
This is, this is this Paul Irvine group.
Do you know Paul, by the way, Matt, I don't know Paul,
so you should reach out and put in a good word for me.
'cause I made a post that he didn't like.
He called me on it. So, um,
might wanna tell him I'm not a bad guy, but, but,
but I'm making, um, posts in here.
I'm looking to see, um, what works,
what doesn't work in here.
I'm trying to understand this group,
and they're actually all over the place.
Uh, but the few posts that I've made
have gotten, uh, like this last night,
this will help a open cloth, right?
And I just, I gave some tips that we've learned in this,
in this workshop about stop planning inside of open law
before training an API skill.
Get the doc first, right? Understand your models.
Create your own commands.
Like, look how simple this stuff is.
Look how simple this stuff is. And some people were jerks.
Know-it-alls, whatever, but it doesn't matter. I don't care.
It, it, it doesn't matter. I'm after the engagement. Why?
Because I can come over here on the phone
and now I have 71 people that know I'm providing value.
And I can come over here
and look, are you guys seeing this right now?
Look, and you can be doing this on your wall.
You take the same exact post, you should go create a group.
That group will evolve into other things.
Are, are you guys seeing this right now?
Like it is never been.
I don't know why that one won't do it.
Maybe I met, whatever,
but it's just, it's never been easier to do this.
Ever, ever groups are getting massive engagement.
I don't even know what's going on with the pages right now.
I I have, I could probably go out there and,
and set up a like campaign
and get likes for a penny on all these people
that wanna automate their open clock.
Do you guys understand this?
And so I'm shaking my head going, wait a minute.
I gave 'em a guide that they can put their own picture on.
Uh, I told them I would, uh, install it if they, uh,
actually had a paying client.
You see me blowing up my wall.
I'm taking the stupid little post off my wall
and putting it in Paul's group, um,
and putting it in my own group that I forgot about
while I'm trying to run this workshop,
figuring everything out for you guys,
and line up two launches and run two other companies.
Do you, you guys get the point right?
Now, how many of you're starting to get this?
Here's what I would encourage you to do, um,
and we're gonna find this out today.
Who asked Open Claw to start,
um, creating businesses, start making money?
Who asked that question? Who asked that question?
Matt did. Who else?
You asked it to create a sales page. That's great.
Carlos is brand new on the call.
I'm glad to see you on the call, Carlos.
And just so you know, even though you bought last night,
we'll, you'll get the version too as well.
Uh, but did anybody else
or y'all just sitting here watching me act
like a monkey every day?
Because here's the thing. Take a screenshot of that.
Take a screenshot of that. Who can do this right now?
Live on the call. Who can do it? Anybody? Any volunteers?
Does anybody wanna build a following?
Does anybody wanna make money? Does anybody want people
reaching out saying, Hey, I can I pay you three K to do?
Anybody, anybody, guys,
you all think I'm special?
I'm not special. I forget everything.
I can't figure out how to freaking share the, the zoom call.
You saw me typing like my dad used to do
with two fingers spelling everything wrong.
Come on. You're dealing with the biggest freaking
idiot on the planet.
But you know what I do? I'm an active idiot.
I'm a consistent idiot.
And you'll see that I spell things wrong, links are broke.
S**t don't make sense half the time.
But yet I still get engagement. Why is that?
Because I'm a consistent idiot. Seriously. Seriously.
And if I could do it, you can do it.
So how many of you, let me ask this question again.
Uh, and who, who was going to,
who was gonna post on their wall right now?
Like, we're gonna share a screen.
We're gonna share a screen. You're gonna make a post on your
wall right now.
Who's gonna do that?
I want somebody that is really,
really good at sharing screens
that it's not gonna be a technical challenge, right?
Um, I, I want it to be very, very easy.
'cause this can be very easy. So
it looks like Winston's gonna do it.
Okay, good. Before we do this, how many
of you think you figured something out magical?
You cracked the code something,
even if it's something I showed you how to do.
How many of you took what I showed you how to do
and you went out there and, and you figured it out?
Maybe you trained an API, maybe, like you said,
you got it to build a page.
Maybe. Who's doing that stuff guys? Anybody?
Come on now. Light up the chat.
Who's actually doing those things?
You know, you know, I, um, I wrote some responses last night
and then I gave it to Chad, GPT
and Chad GT's, like, you're a big old bully.
So I'm like, fine. Rewrite it, right?
And then it rewrote it and it was like, oh yeah, good point.
I can see why you think it's a scam.
And I was like, no, you know what? Screw you too. GPT.
Here's the thing, man.
People wanna make money with this thing.
You take the money out of this and I'm gone.
Is there anybody that can disagree with that? Anybody?
Anybody at all? Is there anybody that disagrees
that if there's no money to be made, I'm out?
Yes or no? You guys just wanna spend a bunch of tokens
and have it do a bunch of work
and consume all your time, energy, frustration.
Is that what you wanna do? Or do you wanna make money?
'cause when I went in that group last night, they're like,
oh, you're in a scam.
Blah, blah, blah. You're using it to make money. No s**t.
Sherlock, what do you think it's for?
That's the only reason it's interesting to me.
'cause I can teach it to go out there
and do things so that it can make profits
for people in their business so they can resell it so
that they can create courses so
they can create digital products.
And if this damn thing wants to create its own business,
teaching people how to make money, hoorah.
Oh, but you're a scammer.
You're creating a get rich quick scheme.
If ever there was a time get rich quick. It's now.
Sorry. Is there anybody that doesn't like me now? I'm sorry.
That's the way I'm seeing it.
I think with the technology that's out there
and everything else, we're gonna see our first one person,
one company billionaire.
That's gonna happen. How can it not?
This thing's doing the job of a hundred VAs
and you got a CEO
and now it's creating products and services for you.
Come on. And it's going out there and getting the sales.
Geez man, it's time to get rich quick.
Can everybody agree with that?
So I'm like, look man, there's some, there's some, uh,
screws loose up here.
If you have a problem saying, I wanna make money
with this thing, I don't have a problem with that.
I got zero problems with that. And you know what?
If my little open claw wants to go
and build a product teaching people how it makes money
for me, I'm okay with that.
No problem. Do it every damn day.
Just don't put me in jail
and don't put me on the FTC radar and I'm good.
Yeah. 'cause I believe it can. Okay?
So post on your wall post in the groups
post in my group, when people, like, when people comment,
friend them, message them, thank them, ask 'em
how they're using open cloth.
Come on, come on, you got this.
Now you go to bed and, and watch Netflix and sit there.
Hey John, thanks for friending me.
How are you using open cloth? Come on.
Is there anybody that's getting this
on a scale of one outta 10?
Are you guys getting this right now?
You'll have people wanting to pay you. I'm proof of it.
People will wanna pay you.
But what you gotta do is show people
that you're doing more than just struggling with an install.
Doesn't make sense. But if we're already making money,
then I feel like the oc,
hold on a minute, let me see something.
But if I feel like we're making money,
then I feel like the OC major benefit can be to help
get us more time away from the computer by auto.
Of course. Same with me too. Of course. Same with me too.
But you know what, Josh? I put out a survey the other
day and guess what?
The number one thing everybody wanted to learn, still
to this day, how
to make money selling other people's products.
You got it. You're different.
You have a Shopify store, you're good. Okay?
Have it automate everything for you.
That's what it's doing in my business too.
But everybody else is saying, man, I want this thing
to go out there and make money
selling other people's products.
Here it is. You gotta build the audience first.
You gotta build the audience first.
And then this becomes very, very easy. Halftime, half-assed.
If a complete idiot can do it, then I can do it.
Uh, I got it, Chad,
but my student made her first sale today.
She's posting about my course. Yeah, I don't even,
I don't even post on that stuff anymore.
Time is money. Yeah.
So look, there's people
that already have an existing business and you're good.
And you were here to learn how to automate things
and replace VAs and replace tasks and have a CEO
and have VAs and everything.
You're good. And then there's other people
that are opportunity seekers.
They just wanna make money. Now, what have I been doing
for 14 days showing you how to
automate your business and everything else?
Well, what happened? Y'all started blowing up my messages.
How do I make money with it? How do I make money with it?
How do I make money with it? I'm telling you. Got it?
Does that make sense to everybody?
Does I suggest you do both?
'cause guess what? It don't take a lot of time
to go copy paste, copy paste, copy paste.
Especially when Chachi t can make the damn post for you.
You understand? Especially when Chachi t
can make the post for you.
So look, Matt says he just posted, all right,
so let's go open this up
and let's see what the heck Matt did,
and then we'll look while I'm here,
let me just see, I posted a video.
Uh, is there anybody that is creating courses with, uh, uh,
OpenAI, whether it be through course brow, whatever,
we know it works well with course brow.
Um, but look, I, I went and I I, I posted this this morning.
I, I posted this this morning.
I very rarely put links out there,
but Facebook keeps limiting my account,
so I'm just like, screw it.
I'm putting the link out there now.
But I, I took this video, very, very simple video.
I shot it with the freaking webcam here.
And I took a clip, a very short clip from our workshop.
And I, and I and I, I posted it, right?
I posted it and it's,
it's already getting, it's already getting comments.
Now, am I, am I friends with her? Yes.
Am I friends with him? Yeah, he's on the call.
Am I friends with him? Yeah. Okay, good.
Um, but the reason why I posted it in here, guys, is
because the last time I posted in here, holy crap,
415 comments, I was like, damn right,
A group that was dead.
I still pulled out 415 comments.
So my point in showing you this stuff, guys, is very simple.
I need you to start posting. Do you understand?
I need you to start posting. And here's the thing.
Matt is not gonna get very many comments.
You wanna know why? Because
he didn't tell people to comment.
That's it. I can't hear you, buddy.
I asked people to comment on the one below,
which was about getting 'em onto the webinar tomorrow.
On, on, on my profile. Sorry, not on yours.
That's one thing. But why not just take this
and say, uh, type open claw and I'll show you
I should be doing, That's it, man.
And you know what? I keep doing that guys.
I keep doing that. I keep doing that. I keep doing that.
And look, if I don't do it, if, if, if,
if I don't tell people to type open claw,
and it's usually right up here, comment open claw.
If I don't do that, then I don't get comments.
Do are, are, are you guys understanding this right now?
And if you don't get comments, you don't beat the algorithm.
Does that make sense? You, you guys starting
to get this right now, you have to tell people to comment
and what you should be doing.
Uh, you know, there's times I'll reach out to Matt
and say, Hey, can you do me a favor and comment on here?
Um, but I'm, I'm gonna tell you guys right now that
I just keep telling people that.
And it creates a frenzy. It creates a frenzy over and over.
It doesn't matter if it's screenshot,
it doesn't matter if it's questions, it, it,
it doesn't matter what it is.
I just tell people, keep commenting, keep commenting,
keep commenting, keep commenting.
They know something's coming up, right?
Uh, this one was a little bit different.
That was a positioning thing,
which actually worked out really well.
We got a lot of vi a lot of VIPs from that post.
And that lady saw this post
and she's like, Hey, I'm not a big, a big guy,
but I'm willing to pay you three K for it.
Come on. Seriously, I took somebody posted about,
um, somebody posted about how they're charging $1,400.
You didn't think I wasn't gonna take advantage of that?
Come on now, right? Comment, open claw, comment open.
C You see, like I,
I asked Sha Kat make me an image.
Who wants to hire an open class CEO, man?
Okay, let me ask this. I spent 14 days with you guys.
Are you trying to tell me
that you don't have the same skills I do with this stuff?
Is that what you guys are trying to tell me?
You know, I wouldn't even care if you took
screenshots from these workshops.
I wouldn't even care if you took out clips of the recording
and put your, put yourself in front of it
and said, man, I just attended this workshop.
Watch this. You're not gonna believe. I wouldn't care, guys.
It's a limited window. You understand that?
It's a limited window.
We're gonna do this for the next, I don't know,
12 months, 18 months.
It's gonna balance out. Software's gonna become extinct.
The API key is gonna be gonna be charging up the,
but for that API key on all platforms.
And then five to six years from now,
I don't think there's gonna be apps anymore.
I think you're gonna be getting your email through ai
and I think everything's gonna change.
I think apps are gonna be a thing of the past,
so why not write it as hard as you can right now?
Does that make sense? Chad?
Do we have an affiliate link for tomorrow?
No, not yet. Tomorrow's a test I could
totally bomb out tomorrow.
Uh, and the reason why is I'm not,
I'm, I'm super behind now.
I wasn't feeling good last night or yesterday.
I was just some stress going on.
And, uh, I now behind, now I gotta
gotta struggle all day today and catch up, right?
So tomorrow could bomb, but tomorrow is just a test to see.
Uh, what we wanna do is go to the affiliates
and say, oh man, here's how much we made per attendee.
Everybody loved this thing. It's a test.
All right, let's see what Winston did.
All right, let's take a look guys.
If you'll post, I'll help you.
If you'll post, I'll help you. Okay?
So let's, let's look at this.
Now, let me ask this question here, guys.
And by the way, are you guys getting a lot
of value on the call or am I irritating you?
Which one? We'll get to the techie stuff here in a minute,
but on a scale of one outta 10, be honest with me.
Is it good or no? Is it good or no? 10, 10. 10. 10.
10. Love it. 10, 10, 10, 10, 10. Okay, good.
Good, good, good. Okay, so let's look at,
um, what Winston did.
By the way, before I look at this, Winston,
do I have permission to critique you?
Are you okay at that? Some people I p**s off
and then they leave the call never to be seen again.
Okay, good. So let me see if I can share my screen here.
Okay, so here's what Winston just gave me.
Can you guys see this right now?
All right, now, first impression, uh, gimme some,
gimme first impression.
Guys, this thing hits your, hits your feet.
What do you see right away? What do you see?
Do you know it's about open claw right away? Yes or no?
Yes or no? Nope. No clue. Winston.
So that's your first thing.
Uh, how many of you feel like you're being sold
before you even read a word?
Yes or no? Hmm.
Hi, business friends. Anyone looking
for exclusive real estate leads
or home modeling, home remodeling leads?
AI can help, but it can't take a lot of time,
energy, and money set up.
So what if you could just have it ready to go
and all you need to do it goes like this,
Winston, you ready for this?
Holy crap. AI is now bringing in real estate leads.
Did you get that? Winston?
You gotta get attention, man. That's great.
You gotta get attention.
Now, did I say what you're trying to say to people?
You want them to know that you're using the AI
to get real estate leads, don't you?
There's also this implied impression
that you cracked the code of that
and you're actually doing that.
Like, you discovered something like you're surprised.
Does that make sense? Yes, sir.
Do you understand the difference now?
Yes. That's really powerful.
I really appreciate that. That's huge.
Now, put yourself in the shoes of your friends
that are looking at this.
And I imagine you're into real estate. Mm-hmm.
If you were in their shoes
and you saw that post, would it get your attention?
Um, I mean, as far as like, yeah,
I see real estate posts a lot.
I think I, I click on them,
but I don't know if that's any more exciting than
what anybody else is doing.
Well, here's the game, Winston.
The game is for you to get as many comments
and likes as you possibly can so that it opens up further
exposure for you, and
that's the game they're playing. Does that make sense?
Yes, sir. And you become super popular
and then people start reaching out to you.
Now, instead of, I don't, I would say, holy crap,
you might wanna, you, you might wanna say, holy smokes,
you might wanna take what I just said
and put it in chat, GBT
and say, make it a little bit more friendly.
He's a little crazy, right? So you might say, holy smokes,
AI is generate real estate leads for me, 24 7
around the clock, comment leads and I'll show you how,
Ah, I'll teach you the secret. Does that make sense?
Yes. That is gold. Thank you.
How many of you're starting to get this right now?
Now look, it doesn't matter.
Um, it, it doesn't matter what you're trying to sell.
You gotta get attention first.
Nobody wants to buy, but everybody wants to be sold
or no, everybody, nobody wants to be sold.
Everybody wants to buy. I had it backwards.
Nobody wants to be sold. Everybody wants to buy. Got it.
People want a solution. They're willing to pay the money.
Nobody wants to be sold. You're selling them right now.
Get attention, Winston.
So can you rewrite that post and get some attention?
Yes, absolutely. Yeah. Who else?
Now, Winston, let me ask you something.
Do you actually have a solution to that?
It's okay if you don't. This is just sample, that's okay.
But if somebody reach out to you
and say, Winston, I'm a realtor here in Las Vegas,
I'm really interested in your post.
What do you got going on? Would you have a solution to them?
Yes, sir. Yeah. Um, the, uh, real estate newsletter is,
um, the, so the re the whole newsletter hustle.
Um, that's definitely still a big part of my focus
and, uh, selling the newsletters done for you to agents
and investors across the country,
and basically just facilitating that.
So the sales page that I was having, um,
I'll just share the link, uh, real quick for y'all.
Um, so this is live and the sales buttons are live.
And I just published it last night
so I could share it today.
So this is the first go at trying to start to offer.
It is a done for you service,
I'm gonna tell you.
Um, uh, so here's the thing.
How many of you did open create this,
This, uh, no, the open claw one.
I'm still trying to get the HTML into the page.
That's what I'm working on behind the scenes right now.
What did you use to create this,
Um, Elementor Pro on WordPress.
Okay. So I have a feeling
it has the right things on your page.
Um, and, and believe it
or not, in the marketing world,
this page would be frowned on in the media world
and everything else it reads like a newsletter,
which is probably gonna work to your advantage, right?
Um, so that's good. So you created the page.
So, um, you didn't ask Open Cloud to create a page for you.
I did, and I asked it to do it in versel,
but it said, oh, I can't do that.
So I said, can you give it to me in the HTML?
So it gave me the HTML.
So now I am taking that HTML,
and I'm about to publish it into my, uh, WordPress
File Manager website and create that page.
So that's in process, but it didn't create it for me.
Did it give you a link that you
could just click on and see?
Um, It should have,
it should have given you a local link.
So it saves that in on your local system.
And then you should just be able to say, Hey,
can you gimme a link where I can see it?
And you should just be able to
click it if you're on that server.
And then if you like it, then you tell it to deploy to Elle.
Oh. So does that make sense?
Share your screen. I'll show you.
Do you wanna share your screen and I'll show you? Yes, sir.
Yeah, absolutely. Oh, it says, um,
that you disabled, uh, screen sharing.
Okay, hold on a second. All right, go ahead.
All right. So you're clearly on your VPS, your HTML is fine.
I'll paste it. Say, gimme a link. I can click on to see it.
Sugar Is sugar the name of your bot?
Uh, no, Delta Brook.
But she's got a Southern, um, flare to her. And, uh, uh,
So you're, so you're having,
you're having a little flirty fling little affair thing
With your, you know, here I need,
If my open claw starts calling me sugar, I'm
with a Hispanic woman.
She ain't gonna put up with that for very long.
I found the SAU gateway. All right, let's see.
Here's what I can do. Create a beautiful HTMLs page.
Use your Stripe, man, you're close. Did you connect Stripe?
I, um, I gave it a link to the sales button,
but I didn't connect it yet through the API.
Do you wanna connect Stripe?
Well, I missed the, I I missed the part of the call
where you were describing why you did it,
and I got in like right after you had done it.
So I was like, like, oh,
I should probably wait till I see why you did it before I go
and do something, you know?
Well, it's very simple.
Uh, the reason why you do it is
because while you're sleeping, open Clock can take an idea,
go map out that idea, show you how it's gonna be profitable,
create the copy, write the sales page, go into Stripe,
create a product, link it to the button,
create the actual product itself, and then go out there
and start driving traffic to your link.
That's sweet. Yeah.
So you want it to have access to Stripe,
but what you do is you limit the access it has.
So I can show you how to set that up.
Do you guys want to see that? Yes, sir.
I can. So if you'll just log into your Stripe in a
different, uh, panel, if you want,
you can stop sharing your screen so we don't all see that.
Okay? Okay. Unless you're already logged in.
I'm logged into Stripe,
but it's not in the same window as the,
uh, the VPS.
Does that matter?
Well, we need to see it, but
we can see it there on the screen.
Yeah, I can, I can open it up here. Yeah,
That works. All
right. So seeing the top left corner of the screen,
you got this account called Find Your Flow.
Is that the one that you want to use
or do you want to create a different one?
This, this one is perfect, yes or no?
If I was you, if you're using that for stuff
that you already have existing, I would give your sugar,
I'd give your sugar its own account so you can keep track
of those earnings separately.
'cause that's probably something you could
share with people, right?
Yes. Yeah, absolutely. Create
A new, go ahead and create a new account, right?
Okay. Uh, you want to read this carefully, right?
Uh, you don't want one,
you probably want the first one, right?
Yes, I think so. That's gonna create a subaccount.
Okay. Okay. So the name your little sugar bot here.
So it has its own account.
I'm never gonna let that down, by the way, just so you know.
And if you ask anybody on this call,
they will tell you, I will never let it down.
I'll always remember you as Sugar Winston.
Her name is Delta, she's gone.
Oh, sure it is. Yeah.
Delta Sweetie Pie, sugar bum Porcupine. I get it.
All right. So go ahead and choose this. Yep, that's good.
All right. So you guys want to create an account
for your bot, okay?
Don't tie it into like, we have local Newsletter Hustle,
we have the Mastermind, we have Launch Income.
Don't tie it into that stuff. Keep it separate, okay?
Uh, I think you can do the bank and everything later, right?
Want to let you, or just go ahead and choose whatever.
Okay. Um,
so what's gonna happen is the account he's setting up,
it's gonna show in the top left corner, okay?
So go ahead and say done.
Oops,
sorry.
No, you're good.
Now, we can also go into Mint Bird and, uh,
or anything, a ClickFunnels go high level, whatever,
and just grab the link and tell Open Claw.
Here's the link for the button. You can do that too, right?
Yeah, that's what I done originally, was I,
I grabbed the button just for that product, uh,
or the link just for that product.
Yeah. Yeah. But if you want, I mean,
it's pretty impressive when you show people this,
like it can make its own products.
Go grab the link and actually put it in the button
before it deploys it to Elle.
And even when it deploys it to Elle guys,
it can still make changes and update immediately, right?
Mm-hmm. Um, all right, well,
we'll tell Stripe just to take it sweet ass time. Sorry.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. We don't have nothing else to do.
Yeah, go ahead and skip all that.
But you'll put all your stuff in later, right?
Mm-hmm. Okay.
Uh, yeah, you can go ahead and go to the Sandbox.
All right, so if you guys look in the top left corner
of the screen, what was the name
of your little sugar thing? What'd you call it?
Delta Brook. Delta Brook.
We should now be inside the Delta Brook account.
Did everybody see how to do that?
So he's in the sandbox right now.
So if you go to the, uh,
I'm trying to remember 'cause I did it.
Yeah, look, see where it says Delta Brook
Sandbox on the left side.
Do you guys see that right now? So he's got two accounts.
So he is got his publishing one in there,
and then go ahead and pull that down.
Oops. Uh, yeah.
So you should be able to see your different accounts,
see the, he's got the Find Your Flow Publishing,
but right now he's in the Delta Brook, so he gave
his bot its own Stripe account.
Wow. Okay. Now what we gotta do is we got
to limit the scope on what it can do.
So up in the top left, up in the top right corner
of the screen, I think it's under settings, if I remember.
Yeah, go to settings
and then see where it says developers go
to developers on the top, right?
Mm-hmm. Uh,
and then see where it says API Keys.
You're gonna manage your API
keys, okay?
And we're gonna go down to, uh,
where it says Create a restricted key.
Do you see that?
Yes. You can go ahead and create the Key, Winston,
and then what I need you to do is show the
permissions for that key.
Okay?
Is everybody understanding what we're doing right now?
So what's gonna happen is, uh, it is already trained,
it already has the skill on working with Stripe.
You're gonna give it the API key
and it is gonna be able to access your stripe,
but it's gonna be very, very limited what it can do.
Okay? Very limited what it can do.
And that way I can't do any damage.
I was following this thread this morning.
Uh, did you guys hear about the, the lady on meta
or whatever, that was stupid enough
to give Open Claw her email and it went
and deleted out like all of her email.
It was like the Safety Lady or something for Meta.
It deleted. I mean, to me, it sounds like a PR play, right?
I don't know if that actually happened,
but, uh, it just goes to show you what a complete idiot.
Why would you do that? Like really,
really think about safety here, right?
Okay. So if you go back to that now, um, uh,
Winston, I'll help you. Sorry,
I'm trying to not show all the keys, but show you the,
Yeah, what was the top section?
So it said, do you want to provide this key to,
so I'm creating a restricted key, right?
Yes. And then it asked me, do I want
to provide this key to another website,
a third party application, or am
I building my own integration?
You wanna do a website?
I'm not talking about the, I'm not talking about the
bot created in Telegram.
I'm telling you that this lady had a meta, did not use a VPS
installed Open Claw on her personal pc, tried to get it
to manage her email, and it went
and deleted all of her email.
That was a thread I saw this morning.
I'm like, and you work for Meta
and you're that big of an idiot.
Seriously. But, you know, Meta's right on, uh,
the tale of Open Claw with Madness,
open Claws clearly leading the way,
but meta's right behind it, madness is right behind it.
So it sounds like something to get publicity
that sounds bad on Open Claw, right?
Um, alright, so
let me know what you got it.
All right, go ahead and, uh, yeah, so click on Learn more.
I think I'm trying to see where you're at.
We need to get to the permissions for it.
No, that's not it. Close it again.
Now we can't see your whole API key, right?
Uh, you can't, Well, let's set it up
and then you delete your key and go
set it up again. Can we do that?
Okay, perfect. Yep, that'll work.
Okay, so you got your key down there, right?
Uh, which one is it?
Um, the, this is both for Delta Brook,
and this is the API key that I just created,
but I did not set any kind of, uh, restrictions.
Okay? So, uh, go ahead and edit the key.
It's not IP restrictions. Okay?
Uh, hold on a second. It's not this. Hit your back arrow.
Let me log into, um, I did it so quick the other day.
Hold on a second. There's two
different kinds of keys, right?
G there's a general key
and a secret key if I'm, if I'm, uh, correct on that.
Is that correct?
Um, this is for Stripe, right?
Yeah. Let me log, Yeah.
For Stripe, you have, you have to use both of those.
Key one is pub publishable key, and another is Secret.
You have that on the screen?
Yeah. Go to your publisher,
publisher key down there real quick.
The standard one? Yeah. Click on the three dots.
We're gonna get to the permissions, uh, rotate. Heat copy.
I wanna get to the permissions of it and I'm not seeing it.
G Hold on. Uh, click on IP restrictions again.
I don't think it's that.
Um, Let me get,
So you add on your sandbox.
Should I not be in my sandbox?
Um, yeah. Can you try it on live? Maybe not.
Try to sew it to us so you don't link your keys.
Yeah, I'm going to my account too real quick to see
API Keys manage.
So I go to Standard
and hold on, copy.
Uh, I'm trying to understand how I created apps.
I set the permissions for it
and I'm not seeing it on his,
uh, developers.
And then manage API keys, uh,
create restricted key.
Hold on a second. So we're gonna publish
to another site test.
Hold on a second. I'm doing this real quick.
Customize, did you click on
customized permissions for this key?
Um, I don't remember.
I think that's the, I think, yeah, you know what?
That's the problem. Uh, create another key real quick.
There was a checkbox, and I think you skipped it.
So go back to it again.
You're gonna have to delete these keys
anyways, Winston, sorry.
Thanks for playing. That's all
Good. It's
all part of the fun.
If you guys don't click this checkbox,
it's not going to appear.
Okay? So, um,
do you just want me to share my screen
and do it Wednesday? Would that be easier for you?
Um, sure, yeah, mine seems to be going pretty slow,
So, okay. No
problem. All right.
So you guys can see, okay, that I went to settings.
Can you guys see my screen? Hold on,
let me make sure everybody can see my screen.
Can you all see my screen chat, chat,
chat, chat, chat, chat?
Yes. Okay, good. So I went to settings, okay?
And I went to developers, all right?
And I click on manage a i Keys, and now I'm over here.
I'm gonna go ahead and create the key,
and I'm gonna choose this first option up here.
Okay? I'm gonna click continue.
And this is probably where Min,
where Winston missed it, right?
This is probably where, uh, Winston missed it, right?
So I'm just gonna do like, whatever nice
mediac@gmail.com.
Okay? Um, and then we gotta customize the permissions, okay?
So we come over here. This is what I was looking for.
Uh, Winston, see this? You didn't see this, right?
No, I I skipped that. You're right.
Okay, so we're in the core,
and we're gonna go down to customers
and we're gonna set that to, right?
Okay? And then we're gonna go down to payment
and tens right here.
And you're gonna set that to right?
And everything else, um, should be off.
It's kind of different. It's, it's doing okay. There we go.
So let's go back down.
Okay, let's make sure everything's set to none, none,
none, none.
We don't want this thing to have all this access. Hell no.
All right, let's make sure, set everything to none.
And I didn't have to do that the other day, guys.
I don't know why it's making me do that now.
Um, they've like changed their interface
already since I've done it.
Um, but there we go. Okay, so now everything's set to none.
Okay? So let's make sure customers has
the right, okay?
And then the other one is payment intents, payment intense,
which is right here, okay?
And there's actually one more, uh,
there's one more that we need to get.
Uh, hold on a minute. Let me tell you.
'cause I made a note of it. Let me up.
API key for Stripe.
Uh, I have under, uh,
payment intent, right?
And customers, right? What's the last one? There's one more.
There's one more that it needs that's outside of the core.
Okay? So this is, this is under the core right now.
And I'm, I'm gonna tell you right now,
the reason why I know it's changed, guys, is
because when I did it, the, um, the UI looked like this.
See, it had a, it had a menu that opened.
So it's, it's, it is already changed since I did it
the other day, right?
Uh, okay, check out sessions, right? Check out sessions.
That's the last one. Checkout sessions are going
to be set to write.
So we can always go control f checkout session,
set to write, okay?
Those three things, those are,
those are the three things that we need to have.
Does that make sense to you guys? That's it.
That's all it needs. If you give it that,
it's not gonna do any damage.
And it can go in there
and it can take, it can create a product,
and I can, it could put the button on the page.
Does that make sense? Now, it can't, you're,
you're giving it the permissions to this API, right?
So it has payment intents.
If you wanna know what that means, grant access
to payment intents and payment events is permission also
implies the following permissions products.
See, that's how it can create a product, right?
And then customers, what could it do over here?
Grants access to customers and customer events.
The permission also implies the following permission.
Billing clocks. Okay?
And then there's the last one that I showed you,
which is checkout.
And this one, grants access to sessions.
This permission also implies the following permissions,
mandates read payment, intense, read payment links,
read products, read, set up intense read and excuses.
Read those three permissions.
Open Clock cannot do any damage.
So you come over here, I'm not gonna do it,
but you'll go ahead and click on Create Key.
And then that's the key that you're gonna give to Open Claw.
Now, scale of one outta 10,
how many of you're understanding this?
Now,
that's where it starts to make money,
because understand this, it can come up with its own idea.
It can go create that idea. It can create the page.
I, I learned this the hard way, man.
I went and I opened up that page and I clicked the button.
I'm like, what the hell is this? Oh,
you gave me access to your Stripe key.
Remember? I'm like, and you went in there
and created the product and did that.
Yeah, that's my job. Like, works for me, right?
Created the page linked to Stripe, right?
Did all that stuff, okay?
So, uh, that's how you guys are going
to connect to your Stripe.
All right? Now, if I look at, um, this part here,
I got a lot of questions on this part here, okay?
So I don't want anybody to have to pay $30 a month,
$50 a month, whatever.
Uh, we are in approval for this software already.
I'm just gonna give it to people.
I'm, I, I, I don't care about.
I just, I don't, I don't wanna play that game with,
I I just don't wanna play the SAS game, guys.
I'm all about my mastermind and events
and, uh, stuff like that.
But, um, this, this software we're in approval with TikTok,
Instagram, YouTube, um,
those are the three that we're starting with.
And then we're gonna do everything. Um,
but right now, if you wanted
to go get started with them, you could.
Um, and down here, you know, here, here's an idea.
Look, I could take this just like this.
Look like this. I could go on my wall.
Holy crap.
I can't believe Open Claw is posting to all these platforms.
What a dream come true.
Comment, open claw.
If you wanna learn the secret, who's getting this right now?
You're not showing your screen. Of course not. Why?
Why would I change that?
Like, there's no reason why I would change that.
You guys see it, see it
that simple little on their sales page.
I come over here, I grab a screenshot.
Same thing I just told Winston.
Holy crap,
I can't believe Open Claw posting to all my social media.
Comment, open cloth. You wanna learn secret.
Now you wanna know what's badass.
You, you know what I think is absolutely incredible.
So I won't give it access to, uh, Google,
but I will give it access to my Microsoft Office 365
where I could access PowerPoint and everything.
Guys, one of the most incredible things I discovered is
when people, uh, comment stuff like that,
you, you, you don't even have to tell.
Look, we can come over here real fast.
Like I'll show you the old fashioned way of doing it.
Like I've always done it. Uh, I can come over here.
I want you to create a real quick,
um, uh, quick start
on how people can use open claw
with post bridge
to automatically post to all those social
platforms, text,
video, et cetera.
Got it? So now look, look at this.
See, you cracked the code, right?
Let's say that you cracked the code.
Let's say that you sat, you found
that site, you cracked the code.
All right? So look, people comment, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, right?
And now look. Now look, you got all the steps here.
You got all the steps. So if it was me, this is me.
I would shoot a simple little video like this.
I'd be like, Hey man, thank you so much
for posting on my wall and everything else.
I wanna get you started right away.
I know you're super, super excited to take open claw
and get it to post over here on TikTok, Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh man, so many incredible platforms.
So I went to and put together these simple little steps
here, uh, to get you started.
Um, obviously we're friends or whatever else,
but I got a link down below
where you can just go ahead and get signed up.
I'll keep you posted with more of these
videos, more of these secrets.
Again, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Let me know if you have any questions, if you get stuck, uh,
and hey, uh, happy posting.
Alright, good luck.
Take a screenshot of that video, put it on that doc.
Simple Google guys. A simple Google doc.
A simple Google Doc. Just put your, put your video there.
I don't care if it's a YouTube video,
I don't care if it's video, whatever.
They click it. They can watch you video.
Now they're getting to know you a little bit.
And then look what happens. Just take this
and put this, take this
and put this over there on, on a Google Doc.
On a Google Doc, on a PowerPoint.
And when people start commenting, reach out to 'em, right?
Um, hey James, man, thank you so much for commenting.
Just curious, what are you, what are
you working on with Open Cloud?
You got it all installed. Are you happy with what you got?
Uh, by the way, here's the simple little steps, uh, and,
and, uh, come back.
And now we make another post that says, Hey, if you grab my,
uh, Google Doc that showed you how to, um,
or no, you can tell 'em go back to the same post, right?
Uh, do me a favor, go back
to the same post I am sharing the screen.
Yeah, go back to the same post and comment down below.
Let me know what you think of the,
uh, let me know what you did.
Let me know how you posted.
Let me know if you've got it set up.
Do you guys get it? You don't have to build pages,
you don't have to build funnels, you don't have to,
you don't, you don't have to do any of this stuff.
You do. You guys, see, you're watching me.
Damnit damnit, all the hell.
I don't know why Zoom, zoom has changed something.
Look, so I, I just went in here.
I want you to create a, a real quick, quick start on
how people can use open cloud with post bridge,
automatically post to those social
platforms, text, video, et cetera.
Got it. And, and it did this.
Put that on a freaking Google Doc.
Take a picture of your little video that you shot,
and every time, somebody comments, reach out to 'em.
How are you using open cloud? How are you liking?
Are you happy with the install?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Here's a link. And do me a favor, go back to the post.
Here's a link and let me know what you think.
Let me know if you got it. Let know if you're excited, dude.
I mean, the thing that makes this work guys, is
you don't have to come up with a hot topic today.
It's here. It's right in front of you. Do you understand?
It's right in front of you. How many
of you understand the strategy I just gave you just now?
And then what happens? You start banking those docs.
You start banking those docs. Could you turn around?
I'm like, I half-assed it.
You don't have to put a lot of effort into it.
Remember, people want to consume something in five minutes
and have a result in the next five minutes, right?
Um, but you could go and take all those things
and put 'em together and then simply have it
as a front end for seven bucks.
You get all of my secrets.
You see, like I did this with Connie.
Do you guys remember this when Chad GT first came out?
'cause I thought, you know what, you're a lot
more pretty than I am.
So I helped her create those simple little scripts on Hey,
Chad, GPT can help you create recipes.
Chad GPT can, uh, help you come up with your song list.
Do you guys remember her doing that?
Does anybody remember that? And then what happened?
She went out there and, uh, let, let me,
let me see if I can find that for you guys.
I think you guys might really value that.
Ashley, would you guys like to see that? If I can find it?
Hold on a second. That was right when, right when,
uh, Chad g PT started getting hot, right?
It's, it's the same thing.
Unfortunately, I can't do it
because of everything we have going on.
But let me see if I can get into her account
and see if I can show you guys, uh, what we were doing.
We were doing pages the same exact
page over and over and over.
And we were doing, uh, Google Docs, if I remember.
So I'm gonna show you guys, 'cause I think this whole thing
can be replicated right now.
Uh, and she built a huge audience
and then we couldn't keep up with it.
Look, look, look, look, look, look. Hold on.
I think this is it. All right, you guys ready to see this?
How many of you're seeing this right now?
You're not seeing it because I'm not sharing the screen.
How about now? I clicked share. Is it sharing?
Yeah. Look at this. So she was
doing these simple little things.
Let's go look at this. You guys could do this right now
and you should let me, uh,
I don't think we have that domain anymore.
The domain that she was using was, yeah, she lost this,
uh, domain.
So let me just go ahead and set up, uh,
a normal domain real quick.
And is that the one I just set up? Hold on, go to link.
Okay. Look, GPT acts as your motivational coach.
Unlock your full potential with chat GBT,
your personalized motivational coach
to help you crush your goals and overcome challenges.
Look,
Chat. GBT is going
to act as your motivational coach. Yep.
This is so awesome.
Imagine being able to unlock your full potential
with your personalized game plan set up
to help you crush your goals and overcome your challenges.
And yep, Chacha Petit wrote that line for me too.
Now, one of my favorite motivational speakers
is Denzel Washington.
So we're going to put together a plan,
a substantial version of qui tea.
And that will, I will provide you with some informa do.
And yeah, just please provide the relevant
information about the person. And
Are you guys seeing this right now?
She don't even have her picture there.
Okay, but let's look at some of these other ones.
Uh, let's look at this. Here's a Google Doc. Welcome.
I don't know if this link will work anymore, guys,
but we're gonna try it.
Uh, yeah, that link doesn't work.
But let me, let me go ahead and, uh, change the URL here.
Let's get off this marketing. Or she did.
She used to have latina marketer.com
and she lost that one too.
And that thing's now $5,000, right? And so guess what?
We don't lose domains anymore
because Open Claw reminds me when
we're about to lose something.
But let's go ahead and open this up.
She was pretty p****d when she lost it too.
She blamed it on me, right?
But look, this video's a minute long.
Okay, welcome special duck.
I really think you're going to love this doc.
And here in the next 10 minutes you should get an email.
But while you're waiting,
let me tell you what I'm doing here.
The first thing you need to know is you can always come back
to this doc through the link.
It is Marketing Insider doc io Forward slash Chachi PT Doc.
So this is actually very easy
because there's no username or password.
You just come back to this Google
link and it takes you here.
Ed, you're going to wanna do that quite often
because I will keep loading it with new prompts, new secrets
and reviews of a new AI software that is coming out.
I may even invite you to participate in a live training
or event every now and then.
So you should see a series of prompts tutorials down below.
Just go ahead and click those videos
and it will take you to the specific page.
And now you have the prompt as well.
I just ask you to please leave a comment below each
and on each and every one of my tutorials,
share your feedback slide bulb moments,
and anything else you would like me to do.
And that's it. I'll go ahead
and get busy making you more prompts and secrets.
Thank you so much for your support
and I look forward to meeting you all soon.
Enjoy the prompts.
So, uh, I don't know if this survey works anymore,
um, but I'm, I'm gonna tell you guys right now that
we were doing this over and over and over
and over and over for her.
Um, and she was, she was building a list.
It was going really, really well.
And I think we did this in a couple times.
Uh, we created another account for the AI stuff.
Let me see what this is. Uh, go to link how to very quickly.
Uh, I think this is something different she was doing.
Yeah, this is something different,
but right when Chad GBT came out, uh,
we were doing this stuff, yeah, we already have it,
Josh, we were doing this stuff.
Does that make sense? Let me see what's
underneath her lead steps.
Um, let's see if there's anything.
Marketing Insider, Connie, Joe.
Yeah, um, yeah,
she was uncover the UpToDate, Chad GT Strategies.
Lemme see what this one is. Go to link.
The reason why I'm showing you guys this,
that domain's not gonna work.
The reason why I'm showing you this is
because you could be doing this yourself,
and it's gonna be like if you thought the chat GPT was hot,
man, AI now has arms, legs, right?
Uh, it can hear, uh, let's see. I want the Google Doc.
Let me see if I can, uh, get in here real quick
to show you guys how you can use the Google Doc.
Okay, let me see. So that's Pop link.
So now, um, uh, open Claw if I did this right.
Uh, let me see where that's at.
Open clock can just go make this for you now, right?
Um, so let me see if I can get to there.
Where is that at Link?
Yeah. Did she not a lot has changed since then,
but does anybody from back in the day have this Google Doc?
Because I would love, it's in her account.
I can't get to it, but I would love to be able to share that
with you guys, uh, so that you could see it, right?
I'd love to be able to share that
with you guys so you could see it.
Let me see if it's over here. Ah, here it is.
All right, let's see if we can get in there.
I'm going in the back door now since
we don't have that domain.
All right, let's, ah, here we go.
Look at this Chad GPT prompts and secrets.
So you guys put a hook on your wall,
people start commenting leads real estate,
open claw, whatever.
You give 'em a simple little Google Doc, right?
And then on that Google Doc, you tell them, Hey, go here
and watch the introduction or whatever.
See, welcome to my download page of prompts and secrets.
Click here to watch this video from Connie Joe.
And then this video, when you clicked it,
when you clicked this image, it took you to that lead,
that bridge page, right?
And so, uh, then you can see
all tutorials on this page were created
for the purpose using chat GPT new AI platform.
You can get started right now.
Uh, you guys will have an affiliate link to the workshop.
You could go ahead and say here, uh, um, go ahead and,
and get signed up for the workshop.
That's where I learned to do this, right?
And if I come down here, look, look, that's text
and a little image that takes you right to that lead step.
Is this making sense to you guys?
On a scale of one outta 10, how many
of you're understanding this right now?
And you could just keep and just keep adding
and just keep adding and just keep
adding and just keep adding.
And she was doing it. She was doing it. Not me.
She was doing it, right? That's right.
When Chad GPT came out, this whole thing,
let me see if I can show you.
She's gonna get mad at me for doing this,
but, um, I'll see if I can just give you guys this link
where you can kind of, again, chate is not a thing anymore,
but right when it came out, it was hot
and we capitalized on it, right?
Um, and you could do the same exact thing with Open Claw.
Does that give you guys any ideas?
So you make a post on your wall, you tell people to comment.
Now you have either a simple little bridge page explaining
what it was you talked about on your wall,
or you just do a Google Doc.
And then what happens is you could actually charge
for this Google Doc if you wanted to.
You could say, if you wanna see the rest
of my Open Claw AI secrets or whatever, it's all right here.
You don't have to create a course,
you don't have to do anything like that.
And I'm sure, uh, let me see something.
I'm sure that if I show open claw this, let me just ask it.
Um, are you able to create
something like this?
I think I can see it i's, see what it says.
I wanna see what it says
I can access, make it visible, copy and paste content.
Tell me what it is. Hold on a second.
File, uh, download.
Uh, PDF. All right, let's try it again. Download PDF.
Okay, so it's be in downloads.
Uh, PDF, the heck.
Uh, so by date modified,
I don't know where to put it.
Delete seven. It drives me nuts when it doesn't ask.
Where do you want put something, right?
So let me see up here.
It's inside of this guy. Fine.
All right. I, I know why that makes sense.
Okay, so come back over here.
File delete seven.
All right, let's just see what it says.
Let's just see if you shoot the video
and you put it in Dropbox,
you put it in Vimeo or something else.
Can it keep updating something like a Google Doc?
Um, what you could do, here's an idea for you.
Uh, how many of you, how many of you would like to know how
to get around that time in the chat?
Lemme know. Let's see what it says. Absolutely.
This is the lead magnet. I can create something
similar for open claw.
Here's what I see. Welcome section video
tutorials, option number one.
Option number two. Here's what I'd like to do.
I'm going to give you a video.
You come up with a hook, create the bridge page,
then update the doc
automatically so the existing
users, uh, see the new edition.
Then I want you to write an email.
Then I can send out, got it?
All right. Is everybody starting to understand this?
So even me, like I told you, it's a hard transition.
I'm thinking that you still gotta go in there,
you still gotta click a button.
You still gotta create a lead step.
You still gotta open up Google.
No, you don't have to do any of this stuff. Look, got it.
Let me confirm the workflow.
I'll watch the video, create a compelling hook,
build the bridge page, update the Google Doc,
write a broadcast email,
and you can do all automatically.
Now, what I'm out to prove is that it can create the video
for you too, but I'm struggling with that.
But it can do it all for you automatically.
Does this make sense to everybody?
On a scale of one outta 10, how many
of you understand what just took place?
So here's the solution. And I did this, okay?
I went and created a Google account
for Pacino.
I'm not gonna give it access to my email,
but I created a Google account for him.
And what does that mean? What does that mean?
It means that he has his own Google Docs
and his own spreadsheets.
And so what that means is he can take the video
and automatically update the Google Doc
and then I can create a pop link and I can forward it there.
Does that make sense? We don't have an AI bot studio.
Josh, you're so off track, it's not even funny.
Does that make sense to everybody? Time to chat.
Let me know. Just ignore anything
that's irrelevant in the chat right now.
But if you do have problems connecting,
I want you to put your hand up.
Okay? All right. So this is how you have to start thinking.
You have to start thinking about, okay,
how can I automate that?
When we, you got existing tasks,
you got opportunities I just gave you.
How many of you saw the opportunity I just gave you?
We've been talking about it on the whole call.
You have an opportunity to go out there
and build a huge brand, build a huge list, make a lot
of money, and ride this thing out for the next five years.
If you follow what I'm telling you right now,
and I had Connie doing it now am I gonna have
her doing it with Open claw?
Probably not. It's a little more techy than Chad GBT was.
And plus her business is taking off.
I don't even know what to do over there, right?
So, um, this can work.
And if it has its own Gmail account, which
ours does, I think I created Pacino 20.
Pacino bought 20 twenty6@gmail.com.
I haven't given it to 'em yet
because we created an agent email address.
But now I can see where it would be very, very useful
if it could create the Google Doc.
So now watch this. Let me just try to do something.
So if I gave you, okay, you have,
um, I'm just gonna do this real quick.
You have an email, hold on, let me, let me grab this.
I'm gonna show you guys something real quick. We're gonna,
we're gonna test this theory here.
We are going to test the theory.
How many of you can see the light
with posting on your wall with this stuff?
How many of you can see the hook post
that you can make out there on your wall right now?
Anybody who can see this?
'cause we're gonna automate this process.
So, uh, gimme just a minute to come up with this.
Uh, gmail.com. Hold on a second.
Uh, where is it at?
I'm gonna give Pacino its own email right now.
Uh, 'cause I know I got it. I just gotta remember.
Open Claw. Uh, do you know
what his email address is by chance?
G? Let me see.
Um, this Robin Palmer thing,
that must be you right, Matt.
Okay, hold on a second, guys. I, I just gotta find it.
Never note real quick. And I'm trying to get out
of the notebooks here.
Yeah, we're up. Palmer's make, sorry. Got it. Okay, perfect.
Um, I'm just bombarded
with all these VIPs at the top here, okay?
Hold on. Uh,
open claw prompts.
Um,
are you able to find it for me by chance?
Uh, g do you have access to that card?
Um, it's not coming up in the search. Let me check.
Claude Bot. I'll bet it's here. I'll bet it's here.
Hold on a second. Got it. Okay.
So, um, here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in the chat.
Let just a second.
I'm gonna train him in a different chat real quick.
I'm gonna say here is your
email, Okay?
So I'm gonna give him access to Gmail right now, okay?
And, um, hold on a second.
I, So
he has access to Gmail, so I don't think he needs
to be trained on Gmail, but now
let's go ahead and continue with this.
Okay? So I'll keep credentials private, okay?
So now I'm gonna say, um, now
that you have your own Gmail, now guys, I wanna be clear,
I did not give it my Gmail.
Okay? I did not do that. It's got its own Gmail.
You can create docs.
Let's see, now
that you have your own Gmail, you can create docs.
Okay?
All you guys are gonna like this.
I think this is gonna work really, really well.
Hold on a second. So let me go to,
um, gimme real quick.
Uh, good question. Let me check what I have access to.
I don't have docs credentials set up,
but here's what I can do via here.
Okay? But it should have, uh, option set up Google API,
um, uh,
yeah, set up access.
I might need to get on the server for a minute,
G if it's gonna set up its own access,
You mean the VPS?
It can get a Google API. Yeah. Okay. It wants me to do it.
Open project create enable docs. API.
This is something I've never done before, guys.
So, um, yeah, can I get in the VPS? Yeah,
You can get into VPS.
All right. So instead of me trying to do all that stuff,
I'm just gonna go ahead and open up remote desktop.
Uh, we're gonna go inside of here. Okay?
So now we're over here and I'm gonna go ahead
and open up Google real quick.
Uh, google.com and I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna go to Gmail.
And which Gmail is this?
Ah, here, he's got his own Gmail already.
Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead and turn this on.
I'm gonna say, can you go ahead, can you
go ahead and
set up the Google a PII need you
to create docs
and sheets in your account.
I'm logged in and the extension is on.
All right, let's see what we got.
Normally I could do it myself, guys.
It's just, I'm not on my game today. Okay?
I'll set up the goal. API for docs and sheet access.
Let me navigate.
All right, so let's see if it comes in here.
Oh, now it went over here. It's in one of these ones.
Uh, it has a hard time clicking this, right G?
Yeah, and this is like the Google console.
I don't know what it would do.
I've never tried it with that.
Well, we're gonna find out, right?
Okay, I'm having trouble with the browser connection tab.
Keeps getting lost. Um, I click
that check box, try again.
Okay, so this is the one that's on.
All right, so I helped it get past that checkbox.
I don't know if it'll ever be able
to click that checkbox, guys.
'cause it's there to make sure you're not a bot.
It, it's clearly a bot, right?
Um, all right, so let's see what it's doing now.
Uh, I open the fresh Google Cloud.
Can you click the open claw extension?
Uh, this is on, yeah, hold on.
Let me see what else is going on.
Okay, this is, I'm gonna turn it off. Back on.
I'm gonna tell it. It's on now.
Close this, close this, close this.
Okay, there we go. So it must be doing something.
So it's gonna select a project. What the heck is that?
I have no idea. So it's gonna name a project.
You have 12 projects remaining.
Do you know what a project is, g?
Yeah. You have to have, create a project just
to get the API key.
Okay? So it's creating a project called Pacino Workspace.
All right,
let me see if it's talking to me over here.
Great. The Project Pacino workspace being created.
I can see the progress notification.
Let me wait for a minute. Okay.
Does everybody understand what's happening right now?
Type in the chat. Lemme know if you get this.
I didn't wanna do this stuff myself,
and I think it would be kind of complicated
to explain to you guys.
So we can just tell it. Hey, here's browser control.
Go set it up yourself.
Yeah, Google's API clearly is complicated.
Okay, so there you go. There's the Google sheets.
A PII told it. I want you
to be able to create your own sheets.
I want you to be able to create your own docs.
There's really nothing to explain.
It's setting up APIs for its own Google account.
And I just told him to do it himself.
And so I turned on the browser and here's the Google docs.
API.
Okay? Yeah, I, I would not try
to figure, I would not try
to figure out the Google API yourself.
And again, I cannot, I cannot stress this enough.
Please do not give it access to your main account.
Never log into your main account.
Guys, when you're on your fricking VPS,
you do not log into a bank.
You do not log into a credit card.
You do not log into Google.
You do not log into anything where there can be damage.
Does that make sense?
Does everybody get this right now?
I don't want you come blaming me when it deletes all your
email and it can do a lot of damage.
Don't give it access.
All right? So it's gonna go set this up.
See, all this would've been really
complicated to teach you how to do.
So anything that's complicated now, especially when it comes
to API, keys, text setups, uh,
it can do all this stuff, right?
So there you go. It's putting in its own email address
and I'll probably need to click this, okay?
And I'll click create.
All right, now let's see what it wants to do.
Now let me see what it says. Google Sheets.
API is being enabled. Let me know. Okay?
We only have to do this once, by the way, guys,
a client is used to identify a single app.
Okay? See, it continued.
It got stuck there, but it continued.
Okay? So here it goes again.
It was easy to give it its own Gmail account.
Now what it's doing is it's creating APIs
so it can create its own docs,
it can create its own spreadsheets.
It can also probably create its own calendar.
Uh, it could do all of that stuff, right?
So let me ask you a question, G.
Is there a way, the calendar is the one that I'm kind
of comfortable with right now based on what I'm seeing here.
I could give it access to just my calendar only, right?
Yeah, that's what we, you would do,
like you'd say select one app to give access to,
and that that's how we get the API key.
Yeah. So I could even guys, um,
I guess there's a workaround if you
wanted to do it like this.
If you were going to have it set up like your calendar in
your own personal account, I could log in like this,
have it, do it in the middle, it is done, lock it out.
Does that make sense? Once it gets the API key,
it does not need your credentials.
So if we did log in and we let it go, set up the calendar
or whatever, the minute we're done with that,
the minute it sets up, the minute it gets the API key, uh,
we would change our password so it couldn't get back in.
All right? The Google sheets, API is being enabled.
Let me wait for it to complete API.
Okay, so
open clock and go rogue.
Of course it can, there's no,
that doesn't even need to be set anymore.
So, but if you don't give it access
where it can go rogue, then you're safe.
Yeah.
So does that mean it's done?
Um,
okay, so I'm gonna come back over here.
I'm gonna turn that off. Okay, cancel.
Okay, that's off now, right? It is off.
Yeah, I turn it back on. It's on cancel, it's off.
Okay, so let me come back outta here.
And, um, can you
create Google Docs now?
So what I'm trying to tell you guys is if you shoot a video,
if you do a demo, simple little demos like
what Connie was doing, it can,
can automatically create bridge pages for you.
Or if you just want to have a series of docs that you give
to people, it can create the doc.
Make sense?
So we're gonna see what it says.
We're gonna see if it can create a Google Doc. Now,
while we're waiting for that, let's see what Kenny posted.
Copy link. Open this up.
I asked my AI system how to make money with it.
Answer is powerful. I've been building out my open client,
set up, fully connected, automated.
Make sure you remove this.
There's nothing that says chat GPT more than that.
And what I would do is I would replace it with dot, dot,
dot afterwards and then push this to the next one
because Chad, GPT never does dot, dot dot.
So when people see it, they don't assume,
but stuff like this, stuff like this is tall tail signs
of Chad GPT make sense?
So, uh, make sure you don't have that there.
So today I ask a simple question,
how can I monetize the system?
Here's what it told me. AI automation agency's potential
content production.
Uh, this isn't theory, this is open, connected, uh,
and the crazy part, okay?
So I'm gonna go ahead and, um,
take this, okay?
Um, 31 minutes ago,
you're already getting comments, dude.
That's not from the call, right?
Uh, what you don't wanna do, drop a comment. Open claw.
You never want to do this, guys, I have to do it right now
'cause my Facebook's restricted.
You never want to put a link here
because when people see this, there's nothing special.
Make people comment down below to get the link.
Does that make sense? Are y'all starting to see this?
If you guys, um, can, can like, and comment here
and, uh, everything else, right?
Uh, this is awesome.
Open on in.
Okay? So I, I don't care. You guys can do that stuff.
But let's, I, I, I want you to learn how to create a hook.
Okay? So I'm gonna take what you have here
and I'm gonna come back over here to chat.
GBT I'm gonna say, can you help me
take this post
and make a, uh, exciting
attention getting hook out of it?
That's going to get comments. Okay?
The key is hook. The key is hook.
If you can't do this naturally,
then you need to do it this way.
I asked my AI how it would make me money if it replaced me.
The answer is smarter than the business
plans I've seen this year.
And it already had four revenue streams built in.
Comment, open cloth. You want to see what it said?
Anybody curious with this?
Anybody at all
see the difference?
Kenny, pattern interrupt.
I asked my a, I said, how would
you make money if you were me?
It didn't hesitate. Outline, automation, agency content,
machine membership model,
lead generation, cost three companies.
Most people don't realize it's possible yet.
Common open call. And I'll show you,
I like the first one better.
I think we're 12 to 18 months ahead of the most small
of most small business owners today.
Ask my AI system how it monetize itself.
It showed me four built in revenue.
Guys, give me a hundred,
give me 20 attention.
Getting hooks for open claw.
Actually, let me do this. Hold on a second, guys.
Give me, um, a hundred attention
getting hooks, hook posts for open
claw that I can use on Facebook
to get engagement and get people to comment.
I want shock and awe.
I want fear. I want opportunity.
I want attention.
Open claw has arms, legs,
eyes, ears.
Uh, in six months, all white collars
jobs have been gone.
Uh, what's it called? Fiverr is down, uh,
95%.
Uh, ask a lot of questions.
Get the engagement right?
Horrible prompt, but I'm just talking, right?
Horrible, prompt. Perfect. If you want shock, fear,
opportunity, curiosity, comments here, a hundred shock
and fear hooks.
In six months, white collar jobs won't exist. Are you ready?
Fibers, traffic is collapsing.
What happens when AI doesn't need you anymore?
If AI can do your job, what's your plan?
Would you hire a human or a 24 7? AI never sleeps.
What if your replacement is already online?
Okay, now I'm gonna say, um, good hooks,
but make posts out of them.
Somebody could go and create a software
that does this actually.
Okay? Make post outta them. Okay?
Do you guys see how easy this is? In six months?
Most white collar jobs won't exist the way you know
them, not because of recession.
'cause AI doesn't get tired, doesn't hold on.
I want you to make it super personal
and imply the poster
has cracked
the code.
Yeah, okay. One, we're supposed to figure this out fast.
What I'm seeing in the AI right now
is not what most people think it is.
It's not a chat bot,
it's not content help, it's an operator.
I gave my access to tools
and started building ideas, pages, products,
emails while I slept.
I'm not exaggerating when I say this.
Most white collar jobs won't survive. What's coming?
The people who learn to control this will win.
The people who ignore it won't. You can feel it too, right?
Anybody want this?
Does anybody want this sheet? Confession.
I don't feel overwhelmed anymore or not
because I have less to do because I offload execution.
The scary part of work better than I expected.
AI doesn't procrastinate,
doesn't hesitate, doesn't overthink.
It just deploys. What if you knew how to close this
to replace the entire
departments, would you move differently?
Comment, open claw. I'll show you how. Comment. Open claw.
I'll show you how. Comment. Open claw.
I'll show you how, right? Let's see how many it's done.
Uh,
yeah, keep going.
All right. So we'll let it keep going,
but let's see what it says.
And by the way, Hannah is up here, uh, loading replays
and I see that she's been, uh,
training it differently.
Deploy with new theme.
Uh, she's over here building a sales page right now.
You guys see this? I got a VA
that's building a sales page right now in open claw.
So a a VA is building a sales page while
I'm over here talking to it about a Google Doc, right?
Let me check. Credentials were added.
Yes, I see the credentials file.
This is OAuth credentials package installed.
Now I need to authenticate.
This will open a browser for you.
Autos script is running a browser.
Should have, okay, hold on a second.
So some
of this stuff's a pain in the butt to get set up.
I thought we were done. Usually when it gets an
API key, it's done right?
G Connect? No,
No. The Google one is
a bit hard
Access. Blocked.
Okay. Or space.
Yeah, you cannot open there
because the app needs to be approved.
And if the app is not approved, you have
to add the email as a tester.
So we're waiting right now.
Is that the case? We're waiting for verification.
Uh, if it, if it has submitted the verification,
then yeah, but I don't think there's an app to submit.
Okay, what do I tell it g?
Uh, can you add yourself as a test user
so you can get the o Can you say that?
Can you add yourself as a test user
so you can get the OAuth
As the app is not app?
Okay. Yeah, it's fine.
Good idea. Here's how to add me as a test user.
Yeah, Google's complicated. Guys. Go to here.
Select project, navigate, scroll to test users. That's it.
Or if you want to make it easier,
you can change the app to internal.
Should I do that?
So,
um, it can go back here.
Can you submit it where it said?
Yeah. Hold on a second.
Yeah, I kind of need you to pay attention for a minute.
I know you're busy, but I'm kind of lost here.
So it says go
here, select
Pro. So,
so just go to that, uh, console. Yeah.
And now you are already there.
Now click on the API and services down below.
Okay? So this is, uh, one,
It says it like project first.
Yeah, you already, you have already selected the project.
You're already there. So on the left side
where you have the oath consent screen, click on that one.
Okay. It should have created one.
Can I just tell it to take over?
Um, yeah, you can tell it too.
Okay. This one's super complicated, guys.
Like, super, super complicated.
Uh, so I'm gonna tell it go away.
All right, I'm gonna open this up again. Let's just try it.
Um, I open the browser.
You do it, you
do t it.
This is, this is the part guys
where I start losing patience.
I don't want nothing to do with it.
All right, let's see.
I'm gonna show you what happened with my video too.
Uh, but I wanna see if it can take over here,
the browser show, the Google sign in page.
Do what browser do you see it in?
Okay, so I'm gonna, I'm gonna go like
this to trigger it again.
It's on the screen.
Come
On.
It should see it, right G
Should I give it this one too?
I can't access the browser right now.
The connection timed out. What's on your screen? Oh crap.
Add yourself as a test user.
I'll add the test user.
I'll add the test user. The browser connection is lost.
Okay, I'm gonna try it one more time
and I'm gonna give up just
'cause I don't have the patience to do it.
Um, go to console. Add the email address.
Which email? Can I just add the same email, G or no?
Yeah, you has to add the same email. Use the same email.
Uh, browser is open.
Oh, I, I I think it's over here.
That one was not open.
Come on. Now I
go to here, add users.
Okay, you know what? I didn't call you.
I can probably do that. So it's saying
go here, add users.
Um, is it a test user? G?
It's already got one though, right?
Yeah, it's added. Okay.
Test user added complete summary. Google Sheets.
API enabled Google Docs enabled. Okay, Google is set up.
So what does that mean? Can I do it now?
Yeah, now I think it's already doing all this stuff.
You can just talk to it in, ask it what you wanna do.
Okay, man, that was a pain in the ass. That is not fun.
Okay. Uh,
can you create a doc now?
Are you sure?
You try one more thing, guys.
Um, it doesn't always, it doesn't always go smooth.
This is the second day that I have had struggles,
um, with things.
We will get this. Do I have any
valuable advice for you with this?
Not really. Um,
what we are doing right now is building an app that will,
um, allow you to give an API key
to Open Claw
and it will be able to access this on Google account.
Does that make sense? So I wanted to show you guys
that this is really, really complicated stuff.
Uh, and we're gonna simplify it very, very easy.
We're gonna, we're gonna simplify it, okay?
But let me show you while we're struggling,
let me show you some of the other stuff
that I was struggling with too.
So the good news is, uh, over here
You are about to see something that shouldn't exist.
A business built in 37 minutes, making money by morning,
and you're looking at the proof right?
Now, this isn't a sales page about speed.
So I went back and forth, back and forth, back
and forth, trying to fix the timing on this.
And then eventually, uh, I just gave up, up
and then it got confused and I tried picture three.
I tried, um, I tried all of these.
I tried, um, what's the big one?
Uh, I can't think of the name of the script.
I tried third party software.
I think there's a way to get it
to do this, but it's gonna take some more work.
37 days to do what I did in 37 minutes.
And here's what's wild.
That's not even the interesting part.
See, it's, it's so completely off.
And then it said, um, what just happened?
It said, um, hold on a minute.
Where did it go? I don't even know what just happened.
Yeah, it said it needed to use Whisper AI
to determine the speed.
So we, we tried to do it with slides first.
We tried to do it. We, we tried to do so much stuff.
You could see, okay, it installed Whisper.
That didn't get better.
Um, the, the reason why I'm showing you this stuff guys, is
it's taking a lot of work
and a lot of money to do what it is we're doing.
I don't want you guys to have to do this.
We are going to figure it out just like we figured out how
to create sales pages and everything else.
Uh, we are gonna figure it out.
And then I'm just gonna hand the skill over to you
where you guys won't have to go through everything
that you're seeing here on the screen.
You won't have to set up APIs like you saw today.
You won't have to go back
and forth with this is three minutes long
To see something that shouldn't exist.
A business built in 37 minutes, making money by morning
and you're looking at the proof from.
So what's incredible though, the,
the reason why I'm liking this is
because it does
have the capability to do it, right?
You guys are seeing that. Is everybody seeing it? It does.
And it asked me, it said, do you want to,
why do you want have black background?
Is there anything specific?
You know, so it's, it's,
I can teach it the very best in marketing
and all that other stuff.
It's the timing with 11 Labs
that is the problem right now.
Does that make sense?
So all of that stuff is a little bit
of a struggle,
but, uh, what we're going to do for you guys, we're doing a,
um, let, let's look at this one.
I built one in 37 minutes while my human was asleep.
Thinkers outline endlessly.
Like, okay, great, so you brought in a voice, right?
You told me it was perfect.
No, it was nowhere near perfectly synced to the audio.
So we just got a, you know, this is nine o'clock last night.
We just gotta crack the code to it.
It was kind of discouraging that I went to bed
and didn't have the solution, but I will get it
because this is a very, very important part of our business.
And I want this thing to create the business,
create the page, create the video,
do do all that stuff for you.
The only thing that I think you're gonna have to do
is create the social accounts because, oh, what's that?
The price? It's a milkshake. Is that lunch?
I just want you to create the social accounts
because I don't think you're gonna have the bot, uh, be able
to create the social accounts.
Is that fair? The script does not have an API
now, but, but understand this guys.
This is a thing, right? Give 'em three months.
Everything will have APIs.
Just give 'em a little bit of time.
Uh, APIs up to this point have been very, very sloppy.
The docs have been sloppy half-assed
because the only people ever needed docs were developers.
The customers never needed API Docs
unless they really knew what they were doing.
Now, every AI is gonna use API docs. Does that make sense?
Lemme look at the post you posted on your wall.
If anybody else wants to share their post
before we leave, um,
and I'll, I'll look at the, the GPT, see if it finished.
Um, but it'll give you guys a good enough start.
So 40 years ago, I was sitting in the front
of a glowing monitor, writing code, green text,
black backgrounds, when the form finally rendered correctly.
Um, here's the thing guys. You gotta learn what a hook is.
What? Why are you doing that?
You gotta learn what a hook is. Does that make sense?
I don't understand dog.
Oh, y'all learn what a hook is, okay?
So Steven's missing the hook.
And not only is he missing the hook, uh,
not everybody's gonna read through this.
So right away, you might notice at the top of my stuff,
before you even click to read more, it always says comment,
open claw comment, secrets, comment leads.
Some people don't even read through.
They just see a bunch of people commenting
and they comment down below.
Is that making sense to you guys? So he's telling a story.
It's a good story. But now let's take the story
and, uh, we'll tell chat.
GBT let me see how many it's given. Okay?
I'll give this to you guys.
Share copy link.
Okay, here's your, here's your chat.
Oh, in-Out Burger, I knew I knew that Cup.
How Healthy In-N-Out Burger. Yay.
I'm act like you don't, I cannot stand in now Burger.
All right, let me see. So we'll take this over
here, copy this.
I'm gonna take Steven's post and I'm gonna tell it.
What? Yeah, I'm on the workshop.
Yeah, and you're like standing
there being all weird and everything.
You guys should say hi to Connie.
She didn't know you guys were on the call.
Sorry, I thought it was just G can you make No,
it's not just G Day 16.
Can you make a hook post?
They're all saying hi to you, by the way.
It's All right. Hook post.
40 years ago, software waited for me. Today it works for me.
I used to sit in front of the green screen
when the form da da.
Now open Claw doesn't wait, da da da.
So it's simplified, spaced out more.
But I'm gonna say hook 'em right
away Fast.
Get 'em fast, fast, fast, fast. Got it.
40 years ago, software waited for me. Today it works for me.
So Steven, this is not your style,
but what I want the first line to say is,
holy crap, do you understand?
Do you get that? You gotta give 'em a reason
to read your story.
The first goal is you gotta make 'em stop.
So you make 'em stop, then you gotta hook 'em right away.
And if the hook is good enough, it justifies your story,
guys, I don't think that's gonna change
in the world of marketing.
Does that make sense? Now if we can back this up
with an image, it's gonna be really, really good.
Okay? Um, alright guys,
I think that's where I'm gonna conclude.
I'm gonna go work with the team, um,
and see if I can get ready for tomorrow,
Chad nice.com/thursday.
Does everybody got that link?
That will be the link to tomorrow's call.
Um, and I'm gonna put myself on the line, man.
I'm gonna open that thing up
and tell it to create a business first thing
and God help me, Right?
But that's what you gotta do.
You gotta put yourself in the box.
Gotta put yourself out there. So if I can do all that stuff,
y'all need to start posting.
Can everybody agree to at least do that? Type the chat.
Let me know if you'll do that. How many of you are going
to scream from the rooftops?
What I want you to do is just get used
to screaming from the rooftops.
You won't think anything of it anymore.
You'll recognize a good hook.
You'll hear something, you'll see something.
Uh, Connie was laying in bed this morning,
I think it was Joe Rogan and
Joe Rogan was interviewing somebody.
And uh, that guy told him in five to six years,
there will not be any more apps.
You'll check your email from ai,
you'll get your music from ai.
Apps will not exist. What a great hook.
I can give it to Chad if you think
and say, make a hook out of this.
Is everybody getting this right now? No call tonight.
Does everybody get this?
Everybody got it?
Yeah. So how many of you're gonna post on your wall?
Just become a h****r man.
Start posting, start posting, start posting. Hook 'em.
Hook 'em. If ever there was a time to hook 'em,
it's now man.
Everybody's biting.
The fish are biting,
the fish are biting every kind of bait you can put out there.
Multiple poles, different ponds, different groups.
The fish are biting. Okay? 2:00 PM Pacific Standard time.
Um, and even though we couldn't get the damn Google thing
to work, I know it can,
but I just don't have the patience for it right now
'cause we're already two hours in.
Um, you could still create a bridge page
or you can create a lead step.
So shoot the video, show him the clip, show him
what you did when you get the hook.
And just ask Chad, should you,
or I'm sorry, ask Open Claw
to make the bridge page, make the video.
You guys got it? Does everybody got it?
Four slash lead Step four slash bridge page boom.
Should be very, very easy. Yeah.
And by the way, what you're gonna see, uh, the mockup
that they showed me this morning, I could show you
'cause I spaced it out in Photoshop.
Um, this is what the, uh, lead steps
and bridge pages are gonna be looking
like here in a couple days.
See that? See the difference?
And so now Open Claw is just gonna,
it, it already does that.
Um, but it's gonna create those styles for you, okay?
So everything is being reworked, everything so
that when Open Claw creates it, it looks beautiful.
Yeah. All right guys, thank you so much.
Hope you got a lot of value on the call.
Sorry for the techie stuff.
Um, that just flashed on the screen.
Are you saying you didn't see it?
I'll show it to you one more time. See?
Does everybody see it now?
All of our sales pages, all of our lead steps, all
of our bridge pages, all of our newsletters, all
of our quizzes, everything's gonna have this look,
everything, and you'll be creating it with voice commands.
Damn. Pretty incredible, right?
All right guys, I'll talk to you soon. Bye-bye.